hi guys Karen Warren was film courage
the radio show and we just finished a
great episode with Tulsa Oklahoma
filmmakers Oklahoma Ward and Nicole
Alonzo we had our friend Nick Murphy in
studio with us also a filmmaker I don't
spoon pictures and just curious what
your take was from being in the studio
live radio connecting with kindred
spirits across the country how was it
for you I think it was this I know
it was great it was really really
awesome I felt finally kind of like I
was like this is must be how Kevin and
bean feel and I'll k-rock cuz like you
sitting there with the headphones hear
everything it's just like you guys are
there but yet I hear you like very
clearly and I hear them over stay was it
was amazing i i i really love how
internet radio was probably where the
future is going as far as radios goes
because everything is everything segue
into down a little meat downloadable
media and it was really awesome too to
connect with two filmmakers two very
passionate dedicated filmmakers who I
probably never we got a chance to me
without without that stuff and to sit
with two awesome talented people as well
so I was very cool yeah from the
interview there were a lot of things
that I took away from today's interview
one of which was how you know filmmaking
there there's a lot of sacrifices and
you know David and I have experienced
that and so I really connected with what
they were talking about as far as you
know having to be frugal and you know
not accept sort of social engagements
and things were there things into
interview that really struck out at you
like that you really identified with uh
yeah I was really impressed with the
fact that he got a girlfriend doing that
because I do that for years and they're
like what you don't make any money okay
um no but I I think it's great it is a
sacrifice you know it really is and you
gotta really want to do that and these
deep these guys have definitely
sacrificed so much and so it it it
struck a chord with me and unfortunately
besides us oh and nooses not to talk
battle anyway but unless you live that
lifestyle a lot of people don't
understand that you know to them they
don't quite understand why you make that
personal sacrifice you know for myself
when i was 18 i moved do 2,000 miles
away from friends and family didn't know
anybody out here you know and that was
my sacrifice as being that far away from
everyone and trying to you know struggle
every day and do the best you can so
yeah so I really related though a lot of
what they were talking about it's true
all over you know sorry here to be a
filmmaker another thing that Oklahoma
and Nikki talked about in today's
interview was that you know it is hard
to find an audience and also an audience
that will support you both emotionally
and financially and and we talked about
social media and you know it's a it's a
tricky thing because you want to promote
yourself but you don't want to be so
aggressive a turn people off you know
and I'm just curious what you took from
what they were talking about as far as
getting an audience someone that will
you know maintain stay with you and
actually back you and purchase your
films and also the topic of social media
um building an audience is I mean I I
think you brought up a lot of valid
points when he was talking about how
there's like one filmmaker had fifteen
thousand followers but of those 15,000
people maybe only 200 would actually buy
or watch the film I think that's a valid
valid point but my I think what I would
like to add on to that just from from my
experience and people this is my opinion
you take away your like and leave the
rest is that's 200 more people than you
would have reached otherwise and maybe
those two hundred people out of those
they'll maybe tell somebody else I just
all this great movie you know it is word
of mouth so numbers I mean I I think
filmmaking what we're trying to do at
least what what I'm trying to do is just
make a film first and foremost and then
the audience will come when you put it
out there you know like it's i'm making
a story for for for them this is this is
my story you know you like if you not
like it and if they do they're going to
stick with you you know like it is sad
that that we live in a world we're so
disconnected from each other because of
social media it's a huge disconnect from
actually talking to people and but on
the flip side of that i feel that we're
making films to reach people and as long
as you reach one person that person will
follow you that would be your diehard
fan to me at the time and you should
ignore those 200 people just because the
14,800 people didn't buy your film and
so i think that there's a flip side to
do both and you should certainly look
into positive as well you know and but
he's right it is it's a tough market to
find out kind of build an audience and
for myself I don't think I've ever like
charged his to watch one of my films I
just can't do it it's a strike you
should just watch this for free and
enjoy it you know I just I feel awkward
saying your give me your ten dollars to
watch this movie you know because if it
sucks they're going to want that ten
dollars back and I won't be able to eat
that night
self-deprecation well I think to a lot
of us have kind of subscribed to that
starving artist mentality I know Dee
Wallace talked about that last week and
a lot of us identify money as like oh
it's evil and we think of Goldman Sachs
and all this greed and stuff that's
happened in the last few years that's
kind of maybe put us where we are
economically as a country right now and
so I think it's hard for us to to ask
for something you know it just feels
weird does and we don't like it when
other people do it so we don't feel okay
about doing it ourselves right and it
repeats on bullets like it was the first
movie that i made where i did a
crowdfunding campaign i never did that
before I never had to ask anyone for
help me move you always come in a pocket
but it was type of mood where I knew
that couldn't happen this time there
would just be no way to do that so you
know at the end of the day we're all
struggling in some way or another and it
is a tough time right now but you're
right it it's a it's just a thing or
people think well I'd love to but you
know I'll do it next week or I think a
lot of people just kind of putting it
off or they don't have it because
something else will come in and affect
them so it's it's hard to go with
audiences it's definitely harder to
raise money so you know it's a struggle
so I did my debbie downer feel I came up
with home of the the problems what are
one of the answers I I don't think I
personally have the answers I don't have
my experience I definitely agree with
with what you and David do and what what
pulsa and Nicole don't do which is the
personal sacrifice is part of the answer
to keep pushing forward I think the
answer is just to keep going and to make
a film that is going to fit inside the
budget that you can't write so if you
move along costs 400 hours can go out
and make a former
you know I've certainly done plenty of
those and what those are great for
especially these shorter ones you can
make all your mistakes on those films
and become a better storyteller with
each one so I think the answer is just
don't think that you need to have ten
thousand dollars to make this movie or a
hundred thousand dollars to make this
movie just go make the movie and make it
fit to what you do have don't think
about what you don't have like I don't
have this all I just won't make it think
about well you know I think this movie
could fit or this story could fit what I
do have oh I have access to this I'll
just go over here and film in this
location because I know I can get that
for free you know I think the answer is
to just keep your options open and to be
your own your own self resource you know
and kind of find that from within and
just tailor your story to what you have
as opposed to one